arrey reduce start with a list of items
then iterate over them to compute a
single value it works just like basic
arithmetic consider one plus two plus
three what we have here is a list of
numbers they're reduced to a single
value using a function called addition
in arithmetic we go from left to right
the results of the first computation is
then added to the next one so it's
actually just a loop but a loop with a
memory take for example in array of
orders from our online store our goal is
to calculate the total dollar amount of
sales across all of the orders in this
array one option is to create a variable
that starts at zero then we'll start a
for loop and increment this value for
each order total reduce can solve the
same type of problem but without
mutating the appstate directly it does
this by applying a reducer function to
each element in that array your job is
to define the reducer function the
signature of that function has two
required positional arguments the first
one being the accumulator that's just a
fancy word for the last value that you
returned from this function the second
argument represents the current element
in the loop or in our case and ordered
object the way we change the accumulated
or remembered value is to return a value
from the function to combine all of the
order totals into a single number we
simply add the accumulated value to the
current value and optionally we can add
a starting value as a second argument
which will set at zero the end result is
the combined order total across all
elements in the array we started with
many things and reduced it down to one
thing in some cases you might want to
start at the end of the array and work
your way backwards you can use reduced
write to start at the end of the array
and work your way to the beginning this
has been array reduce and 100 seconds
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]